they deserve him every [__] day of
the week just like they deserve Tommy
tuberville same [__] thing same
[__] same [__] [__] they
deserve that son of a [__] they made
this [__] bed they should sleep in it
Tommy tuberville even Lindsey Grahams
pissed off at him here here's a little
here's a little CLP from the Senate
because Tommy tuberville held up all
almost 400 promotions in DOD which is
standard oper rasing Senate procedure
where the dod presents their promotions
and the Senate votes on them as a
blanket trusting the dod with their
promotions but Tommy tuberville doesn't
want women in the military because
that's really what he's
saying that's really what he's
saying Tommy tuille has been holding up
military promotions blocking them in the
Senate because he doesn't want he
doesn't want a woman to drive across the
state line to receive medical attention
he she doesn't want her going to the
doctor Tommy Tu rille just doesn't like
when them women folk go to the doctor
and frankly if that means they shouldn't
be in the military then Tommy tuberville
probably thinks that's a good thing
too it's truly what they want that's
what they mean when the military's woke
they mean women's in the military that's
what it
means that's what it means to the toxic
the toxic masculinity masquerading out
there these [__] fake ass incels
thinking they're tough guys like Tommy
tuberville here even Lindsey Graham even
lady G knows he's not a tough guy listen
to this it's about keeping
politics politics out of the military I
did not put it in the military Joe Biden
and secretary Austin put politics in the
military and it's about the right to
life so which is it is it about politics
or is it about you don't want women in
the military because it feels like to me
that I don't know everything's about
politics when it I don't
know comes to the floor of a political
body like the Senate of course it's
[__] po how the [__] what in the [__]
don't how God damn
it it's politics folks it's on the floor
of the
Senate we elect these people as
politicians to represent us in our
Republic Jesus [__] Christ to go make
decisions as
politicians using
politics God
damn it's exhausting that that the Sheep
don't know this these are some of the
most important things in the world to
me and so Mr President I object
objection is heard Mr President from
South Carolina yeah I'll have another
one U let me respond to my C colleague
respectfully we have court actually uh
lady G you should do it not
respectfully you should really I mean
honestly this respect thing is not
getting us very far when you're doing
this [__] where you're you're being
respectful to Tommy
tuberville see that that's the kind of
discourse that I think that we should
rebut enough of that [__] enough of
[__] playing playing Koy with Tommy
to not giving him what he [__] wants
[__] that guy [__] him and [__] scumbag
that's that's funding him because
someone is paying someone is paying
Tommy tuberville to do this Tommy
tuberville would not have the Intuition
or nor The Willpower to continue this
[__] if there wasn't money behind
it no way neither would Republicans
because watch lady G here watch him
watch her him what whatever we have
courts if you think they've done
something illegal go to court that's how
you handle these things the Pentagon has
issued a legal opinion I disagree with
saying this doesn't violate the H
amendment I disagree with it here's
what's going to happen you've just
denied this lady a promotion you did
that all of us are ready to promote her
because she deserves to be promoted she
had nothing to do with this policy let
me say it again everybody in this body
could find an issue with any
Administration they don't agree with and
what we're going to do is open up
Pandora's Box today is abortion policy
if we take back the White House we'll go
back to the Mexico City policy limiting
dollars to be given to overseas entities
that are engaged in the abortion
business some pro-choice people don't
like that what would happen if they put
put a hold on all the officers because
they don't agree with the Republican
Administration there's a reason this
this has not been done this way for a
couple hundred years no matter where you
believe it or not senat harbaville this
is doing great damage to our military I
don't say that lightly I've been trying
to work with you for nine months okay so
Lindsey Graham obviously he understands
it but he didn't get to the point let me
show you the point here uh where he gets
to right about out actually you know
what I want to show you something else
here I know this seems a
little this seems a little petty but if
you look in the background here is that
is that Kirsten Cinema walking in the
background can someone confirm that for
me just saying I can't see anything but
her skirt and her boots but I think
that's Kirsten Cinema in the background
there probably okay so here's the point
where Lindsey Graham he makes the point
but he doesn't get
it which is is not surprising it's not
surprising that they don't [__] get
it the the point is the reason why Tommy
tuberville is stopping this nomination
isn't because of abortion it isn't
because of Wess it isn't because of Ju j
Biden Joe Biden it's not because of
that let me give you a little [__]
hint Lindsey Graham says it out loud let
me give you a little hint he says out
loud here
listen I disagree with it here's what's
going to happen you've just denied this
lady a promotion you did
that you just denied this lady a
promotion you did that it ain't got
nothing to do with abortion it ain't got
[__] nothing to do with
wokeness Tommy tuberville's goal is to
make
sure that there are not women in the
military I told you that months ago when
he was doing
this months ago because the thinking is
well here's the deal here's the deal
Tommy Tommy says well here's the deal I
tell you what we just don't have women
in the military and then we don't have
to do any of this stuff by abortion we
have to do anything about
abortion because here's the thing here
thing there're no women in military we
don't have to give them healthc care at
all see see that's what we don't have to
do we don't have give women anything in
this country they shouldn't have the
right to vote they shouldn't have the
right to travel and in lovec Texas or
Texas in general they shouldn't be able
to go to the doctor's point unless me
Tommy tuberville says that you can go to
the [__] doctor the way that I want
you to go to the doctor I mean if I get
you pregnant if me Tomic tuberville gets
you pregnant then I want you to go to
the doctor get an abortion but if you're
gonna go get an abortion for someone
else other than Tommy tuberville I don't
want you to have it okay you see I don't
want women in the
military that's what the [__] it's been
about the whole godamn time the whole
goddamn time when any [__] some
misogynic piece of [__] some Macho Man
oh yeah Macho Man when any macho man who
hasn't been in the military like Tommy
dville is talking to you about how the
military's less
manly he's not saying it that way but
it's less manly he [__] means that he
does not want women in the military
that's what he means by
Wess listen to it a [__] again listen
to it here's [__] Lindsey Graham
listen to what she says again lady G
will tell you he doesn't she doesn't get
it he doesn't get it whatever but he
says it out loud listen saying this
doesn't violate the hide amendment I
disagree with it here's what's going to
happen you've just denied this lady a
promotion you did
that all of us are ready to promote her
because she deserves to be promoted she
had nothing to do with this
policy there you go she had nothing to
do with this
policy nothing to do with this policy
but she's got a giner she's got one of
them lady Parts they're always focused
oh God they're [__] hyperfocused on
what gender and who's what and what's a
woman what's a woman
she's
qualified to be in this
position
DOD has said she's
qualified the Senate
overwhelmingly wants to individually
promote her which they do not do
normally normally it's a blanket
promotion they do all these promotions
with one vote because they trust DOD to
make these promotions inside their
military
ranks
Tommy tuberville and I've said it for
months and months and months that this
is not about abortion it's not about
wokeness in the military they do not
want
women in the military and if we could
find I almost bet if you could find a
big funding apparatus out there in the
rightwing that is hyperfocused on women
not being in the military and really
honestly you could probably start at
Women's Health Care like them taking
away Women's Healthcare roie Wade
absolutely stripping roie Wade and also
paired with women not taking away the
rights of women to vote I almost bet
you'd find exactly who the [__] is
paying Tommy tuberville to do
this I almost bet you B Bottom Dollar
you could find exactly who the [__] is
funding Tommy tuille to do this who is
pushing him to do
this same [__] people who use
abortion as a cudel the same [__]
people who convince their [__] sheep
that abortion is the only issue you vote
on the same [__] people who who
convince white fragile men that there's
no such thing as privilege and that this
isn't a democracy it's a republic same
[__] same
[__] and here lindsy Graham is
walking smack dab into why Tommy
tuberville does not want to do this why
he doesn't want this
woman to be promoted in the military and
he's he still can't get the [__] out of
his brains to realize what's going on
because if he did he'd call it out right
there on the senate
floor uh Tony Phillips makes a pretty
good point probably harlon
Hitler could
be could be harlon
Hitler that's paying Tommy tuberville to
do this I don't know how many times
Tommy tuberville has went down and sat
and had a reading out of the signed copy
of M comp with Haron Hitler but I'm sure
it's been more than
once what a [__] scumbag Tommy
tuberville
is and it ain't just about our national
security folks you sh I mean you should
be really pissed off especially if
you're a veteran if you serve this
[__] country or if you have family
members that have served this country or
if you've lost family members that has
served this [__] country for Tommy
tuberville some [__] Podunk goddamn
Florida man who is a senator in Alabama
he's a goddamn carpet
bagger is standing in the way of the do
DOD promoting our national security
apparatus to their post to make sure
that our national security isn't at
risk you should be [__]
livid about
that but the fact that all this is about
that Tommy tuberville wants to create
the narrative because that's what
they're doing
[__] that's what they're doing
they're planting the seeds of
narrative that's what Tommy tuberville
is doing that's what probably harlon
Hitler is funding here I bet those
[__] scumbags those Nazi scumbags
have been down in Texas in his goddamn
Hitler Library sitting around drinking
conac [__] reading from the sign copy
of M
pum talking about how oh they can get
the narrative going in this country they
can get the real the internet white
incel Bros to really spark up the
narrative that women shouldn't be in the
military that would solve Tommy
tuberville's
problem what do you think this
is it's an attack on women
folks and it's just not to attack on
women about their Healthcare rights
it's not just about that that's what
they want it to appear to
be they want you to think that it's
about
abortion and it's about [__]
handmaid's tail type
[__]